WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
IN GENERAL, THE LESSON IS BIG ON
ADMITTING THINGS, ALL THESE
THINGS, BUT IN THE CASE OF
ROBERT MUELLER SUSSMAN
YESTERDAY, THEY DON'T HAVE A
CHOICE.
WE ARE CONCEDING ASK HIM WHAT
WAS A TOTAL KIT DISASTER BE AND
HOW IS NANCY PELOSI REACTING
TODAY AND WHAT IS
DONALD TRUMP JR. THINK OF WHAT
HAPPENED YESTERDAY?
BOTH OF THEM RESPOND EXCLUSIVELY
RIGHT HERE IN JUST A MOMENT.
BUT FIRST TONIGHT, THE RUSSIA
HOAX ENDED YESTERDAY.
WE CAN SAY THAT.
IT ENDED NOT WITH A BANG BUT
WITH THE MODELED HALF MEMORIES
OF A FADING OLD MAN SLIPPING IN
AND OUT OF FOCUS.
AMERICA'S GOT TRANSFIXED BY
ROBERT MUELLER'S TESTIMONY
BEFORE CONGRESS BEAR NO HONEST
PERSON COULD COME AWAY AT THE
END BELIEVING THAT THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES COLLUDED
WITH THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT TO
STEAL AN ELECTION.
THAT WAS THE ALLEGATION, YOU
WILL REMEMBER.
AND THEN, AFTER THE MOST
EXTENSIVE VALLEY INVESTIGATION
IN MODERN AMERICAN HISTORY, WE
FOUND THE TRUTH.
WE CAN SAY CONCLUSIVELY ONCE
AGAIN, WHAT WE TOLD YOU THE DAY
THIS ALL STARTED, THE WHOLE
THING IS A CROCK.
IT NEVER HAPPENED.
THEY WERE LYING TO YOU.
THAT'S CLEAR NOW THAT THE DAY IS
OVER.
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN THE
RUSSIAN STORIED WHITE ENDED.
THERE ARE LOOSE ENDS.
FOR TWO AND HALF YEARS, SOME OF
THE MOST POWERFUL PEOPLE IN
AMERICA SUPPOSEDLY SERIOUS, WELL
EDUCATED PEOPLE, VERY SMART
PEOPLE, THESE PEOPLE MADE WILD
AND UNTRUE AND TOTALLY RECKLESS
ALLEGATIONS ABOUT ISSUES
CRITICAL TO THE LIFE OF THIS
COUNTRY.
ALL ON THE BASIS OF NO EVIDENCE
WHATSOEVER.
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE THEY DID
THAT.
BUT THEY DID DO IT.
WHAT SHOULD HAPPEN TO THESE
PEOPLE NOW?
CONGRESSMAN ADAM SCHIFF RINGS
IN.
HE CLAIMS HE POSSESSED ACTUAL
EVIDENCE OF RUSSIA COLLUSION.
HE DIDN'T JUST SAY THAT ONE
TIME, HE SAID IT REPEATEDLY.
>> THERE WAS SIGNIFICANT
EVIDENCE OF COMMUTE COLLUSION.
INDEED, THERE IS, OF COLLUSION
OF PEOPLE IN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
WITH THE RUSSIANS.
I THINK THERE'S PLENTY OF
ABSOLUTE EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION
OR CONSPIRACY.
>> Tucker: IN THE END, YOU
KNOW WHAT HAPPENED OR DIDN'T.
SHIFT DID NOT PRODUCE THE
EVIDENCE.
HE DIDN'T HAVE IT BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T EXIST.
SCHIFF WAS BLUFFING WHICH IS TO
SAY, LYING.
HE STILL IS, ACTUALLY APPEARED
AS OF YESTERDAY, SCHIFF WAS
CONTINUING TO CLAIM THAT THE
TERM CAMPING QUOTES EMBRACED
FOREIGN HEALTH MADE USE OF IT,
AND COVERED IT UP.
IN OTHER WORDS, COLLUSION.
SCHIFF STILL BELIEVES THE COOK
FOR COLLUSION HOAX.
OR DOES HE?
TODAY, ADAM SCHIFF WENT ON CNN
TO CARRY WATER FOR HIS BOSS,
NANCY PELOSI.
IMPEACHMENT MINING NOT BE A
GREAT IDEA, HE IS TOLD CNN
VIEWERS.
BUT WAIT, THAT DOESN'T SEEM TO
MAKE SENSE.
IF DONALD TRUMP IS WORKING FOR A
HOSTILE FOREIGN POWER, AS
ADAM SCHIFF WAS TOLD COUNTLESS
TIME THAT HE IS, HOW CAN WE NOT
IMPEACH HIM?
NO ONE ON CNN ASKED ADAM SCHIFF
TO EXPLAIN THAT CONTRADICTION,
UNFORTUNATELY NOT THAT IT
MATTERS BECAUSE THINK ABOUT IT
FOR A PSYCH.
AND YOU WILL SEE EXACTLY WHAT'S
GOING ON.
ADAM SCHIFF NEVER BELIEVED A
WORD HE WAS SAYING.
I SUPPOSE THE GOOD NEWS IS,
SCHIFF IS NOT DELUSIONAL.
THE BAD NEWS, THOUGH, IS THAT
ADAM SCHIFF IS A SOULLESS LIAR.
AS A MAN WILLING TO SAY
LITERALLY ANYTHING FOR A
POLITICAL ADVANTAGE AND THAT'S
REALLY THE WORST OF ALL.
BEING A LUNATIC WOULD BE MUCH
MORE APPEALING THAN THAT.
NATURALLY, WASHINGTON BEING THE
PLACE THAT IT IS, ADAM SCHIFF
HAS BEEN RITUALLY REWARDED FOR
HIS SHAMELESS DECEIT.
HE IS STILL THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
THAT'S ONE OF THE MOST POWERFUL
JOBS AND ALL OF SCHIFF IS ALL
BUT CERTAIN TO BE THERE FOR
YEARS.
BUT WHAT ABOUT HIS ENABLERS AND
THERE ARE A LOT OF THEM.
THE JOURNALIST, THE FELLOW
LAWMAKERS, THAT HELPS
ADAM SCHIFF TELL HIS LIES.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE EAT, YOUR
MEMBER, WHO BLINDLY ACCUSE THE
SITTING PRESIDENT THE SITTING
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
OF TREASON.
>> THE EVIDENCE SUGGESTS,
INDEED, TRUMP IS, AND HAS BEEN,
UPON OF THE RUSSIANS.
>> WHEN YOU START TO SEE A
PATTERN WHERE HE BASICALLY
FOLLOWS PUTIN'S LIES, THAT WE
HAVE TO ASK THE MOST UNUSUAL
QUESTION ABOUT OUR OWN
PRESIDENT.
>> WHY THIS PRESIDENT SEEMS TO
BE PUTTING RUSSIA'S INTEREST
INSIDE OF OUR OWN.
>> THE TWEET REALLY JUST
UNDERCUTS HIS OWN DEFENSE FOR
THE PRESIDENTS WE COULDN'T HAVE
BEEN SCRIPTED BETTER IF IT WAS
WRITTEN BY PUTIN HIMSELF.
>> THIS IS NOTHING SHORT OF
TREASON BECAUSE IT IS A BETRAYAL
OF THE NATION.
HE IS GIVING COMFORT TO THE
ENEMY.
>> THERE IS INFLUENCE WHETHER
WAITING, OR UNWITTING, BY THE
RUSSIANS OVER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> IS A POSSIBILITY.
A VERY REAL POSSIBILITY.
THAT PRESIDENT PUTIN HOLDS
DAMAGING INFORMATION OVER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> >> TRUMPS EAGERNESS TO SELLO
>> >> TRUMPS EAGERNESS TO SELLT
AMERICA PROVES THE RUSSIANS MUST
HAVE SOMETHING PERSONALLY,
POLITICALLY, OR FINANCIALLY ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Tucker: IMPROVES THE
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS COMMITTING
TREASON.
THINK ABOUT WHAT YOU DECIDE.
THE LAST PERSON IN THAT MONTAGE
WAS NANCY PELOSI.
AS YOU KNOW, SHE'S THE SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE.
THIRD IN LINE FOR THE
PRESIDENCY.
SHE IS THE COUNTRY'S MOST
POWERFUL LAWMAKER.
HE SUPPOSEDLY AWOKE WISE AND
SOBER PERSON.
AND THERE, SHE WAS TELLING YOU,
IT'S BEEN PROVED THAT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
IS WORKING FOR A HOSTILE FOREIGN
POWER.
IS ANY SPEAKER IN AMERICAN
HISTORY EVER SAID SOMETHING THAT
IS IRRESPONSIBLE, MAY BE NOTHING
COMES MIND, BUT IF YOU THINK
THAT'S SHOCKING, CONSIDER THIS.
PLUS HE IS STILL SAYING THAT.
ALEX PFEIFFER RAN INTO PELOSI
JUST THIS AFTERNOON ON
CAPITOL HILL AND ASKED HER,
LISTEN TO WHAT SHE TOLD OUR SHO
SHOW.
>> SPEAKER PELOSI, IN JANUARY,
HE WONDERED WHAT PUTIN HAD ON
TRIAL DATE OF HEARSAY, ARE YOU
ANY CLOSER TO FIGURING THAT OUT?
>> WE ARE IN THE COURTS RIGHT
NOW.
SPEAK ARE YOU ANY CLOSER?
>> WE NEED TO ANSWER OUR
SUBPOENA TO THINK THERE MIGHT BE
SOME SORT OF BLACKMAIL THE
PRESIDENT?
>> I WONDER WHAT PUTIN HAS
POLITICALLY, FINANCIALLY, OR
PERSONALLY.
[INDISTINCT QUESTION]
>> Tucker: THE EXCHANGE ISN'T
LONG BUT IT REALLY TELLS YOU
EVERYTHING YOU NEED TO KNOW.
PELOSI TOLD OUR SHOW THE
PRESIDENT IS A TRAITOR WHO IS
COMMITTING TREASON AND YET, SHE
DOESN'T WANT TO IMPEACH HIM.
HOW DOES THAT MAKE SENSE?
WELL, IT ONLY MAKES SENSE WHEN
YOU UNDERSTAND THE POLICE HE
DOESN'T MEAN A SINGLE WORD THAT
SHE SAYS.
EVERYTHING IS POLITICAL.
MEANING, IT'S ONLY ABOUT POWER.
THAT'S NOT JUST ANNOYING, IT'S
ALSO OMINOUS.
AND HERE'S WHY.
15 YEARS AGO, THIS SPRING, WE
INVADED IRAQ TO STOP A WMD
PROGRAM THAT DIDN'T EXIST.
THOUSANDS OF AMERICAN TROOPS
DIED IN THE PROCESS, TRILLIONS
OF DOLLARS WERE WASTED.
IT WAS THE SINGLE GREATEST
MISTAKE IN THIS COUNTRY IN
GENERATIONS AND YET, AND HERE'S
THE KEY, NOBODY IN WASHINGTON
WAS EVER PUNISHED FOR IT.
THE PEOPLE WHO PLANNED IT WENT
ON TO EVEN BETTER JOBS.
ONE OF THEM IS NOW OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR, JOHN BOLTON.
FIVE YEARS AFTER THE IRAQ WAR,
OUR ECONOMY COLLAPSE.
REMEMBER THAT?
THE SUBPRIME MELTDOWN?
THE SPECIFIC CAUSES WERE COMPLEX
BUT THE THEMES WERE INSTANTLY
RECOGNIZABLE.
THE GREED AND STUPIDITY AND YET,
ONCE AGAIN, NO ONE WAS EVER
PUNISHED.
NOW, FAST FORWARD ANOTHER 11
YEARS TO TODAY, RIGHT NOW
AMERICA STANDS ON THE BRINK OF
YET MORE FOOLISH FOREIGN
ENTANGLEMENTS AND ON THE BREAK
OF POTENTIALLY ANOTHER FINANCIAL
MELTDOWN.
WHY IS THAT?
BECAUSE NOBODY IN WASHINGTON HAS
LEARNED ANYTHING.
AND WHY WOULD THEY LEARN
ANYTHING?
WHEN THEY SCRUB, THERE ARE NEVER
ANY CONSEQUENCES.
IT IS SKATE BY ON THE UNUSUAL
MIXTURE OF AGGRESSION AND B.S.
NOTHING TO SEE HERE.
KEEP MOVING.
IMAGINE FOR A SECOND WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN IF YOU'LL LET YOUR KIDS
ACT LIKE THAT.
WELL, THEY WOULD BE IN PRISON BY
NOW.
SO, MAYBE IT'S TIME TO STOP THE
CYCLE IN WASHINGTON TO BE AND
HOW ABOUT THIS.
IF YOU CAN GET CAUGHT LYING
ABOUT THE BIG THINGS, WHETHER
IT'S ABOUT WEAPONS OF MACK MASS
DISTRICT AUCTION ORB SUBPRIME
MORTGAGES ARE RUSSIAN COLLUSION,
YOU HAVE TO ADMIT IT.
AND SERVE PENANCE.
NOT NECESSARILY PRESENT TIME,
THOUGH WE ARE OPEN, BUT
PUNISHMENT OF SOME KIND.
YOU CAN STAY IN WASHINGTON
MAKING SIX TIMES THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN SORRY.
YOU CAN'T DO THAT HERE NOW,
SORRY THAT YOU'VE GOT TO LEAVE.
YOU GOT TO READ QUOTE RELOCATE
TO CAMDEN, NEW JERSEY.
GARY, INDIANA.
AND DO SOMETHING USEFUL LIKE
CLEAN MOTEL ROOMS FOR MINIMUM
WAGE.
PUT THE LITTLE SANITIZED FOR
YOUR PROTECTION SCRIPTS ON
TOILETS.
NOT FOREVER.